so the Republican party hates
libertarians both little el libertarians
in their party and big el libertarians
in the libertarian party and as they
show their disgust and distaste and try
and punish their legislators what
they're doing is just driving them into
our arms hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason and today I'm talking with
Nicholas our work he is the chairman of
the libertarian national committee or
the LP flight as we like to call it
around here
Nicholas thanks for talking to us thanks
for having me Nick the Trump presidency
so far does it bear out your worst fears
of what he was going to rot the Trump
presidency so far has been tremendous it
is pretty much the best recruiting tool
for the Libertarian Party we've ever had
it's much better than anything I could
develop inside the party he's shown that
the success of republicanism is the
death of Liberty which is a good way to
show people that there's an option from
the two-party system what are the things
that he's done so far that particularly
you think Drive meant that message home
the nomination of Jeff Sessions as
Attorney General you know a man who
walked himself into lying to a senator
during a hearing which shows his
incompetence as an attorney and wants to
bring us back to the failed policies of
prosecuting the racist war on drugs
using civil asset forfeiture to steal
money and things from citizens who
haven't been convicted of a crime or
haven't even necessarily haven't even
been indicted or charged with honey
exactly
basically highway robbery and through
bringing back old failed program of
adoption he's able to work around state
laws to try and prevent civil asset
forfeiture abuse those sort of things
are really putting a lie to the idea
that the Republican Party or the Trump
presidency is going to be any friend to
somebody who favors individual liberty
or small government what is the lp
strategy for the midterm elections and
2020 so we're laser focused on the 2018
midterm elections that's going to set
the stage for 2020 our goal right now is
to have over 2,000 candidates running
across the country as libertarians to
really show our presence as a national
political party to bring in a full-time
person at the
office for candidate support and
recruitment to really go out there and
take advantage of what's going to be a
very unsettled midterm election there
gonna be a lot of people who voted for
Trump who had previously voted for Obama
looking for an alternative some of them
will go back to the Democrats but I
think a lot of them will realize that
that back and forth between right and
left is not a productive strategy do you
see any high-profile Republicans or
Democrats who might defect to become
libertarians either in the midterms or
in 2020
yes we're already seeing that at the
state legislative level with legislators
in New Hampshire and Nebraska Utah and
Nevada flipping over to being
libertarians oftentimes it's not even
them changing what they're doing is more
coming out of the closet and and
removing some of the baggage that
they've been carrying in their old party
and being who they are you know actually
showing their identity I think that's
going to happen more and more the the
Republican party hates libertarians both
little el libertarians in their party
and big el libertarians in the
libertarian party and as they show their
disgust and distaste and try and punish
their legislators what they're doing is
just driving them into our arms what are
the national issues or the big issues
that you think will help the lp really
kind of punch through the next level in
2020 you know I think attacking the
racist war on drugs and trying to end
that that's where a lot of the civil
liberties violations and incarceration
come from and outside of a few isolated
people in the Senate or the house
neither of the two all parties are
addressing that issue you know to date
no state republican or democratic
parties have pushed for cannabis
legalization it's always been through
voter initiative or through popular
pressure reforming the immigration
system to have open immigration for
peaceful people where people can come in
and we know who's going to be here so we
can address those safety concerns people
have but do it in a way where we're not
deporting people who have been here for
20 years and sell us tamales around
Christmastime the other thing is free
trade we really need to have a party
that supports free trade realizes that
while it creates some disruption
it makes all of our lives better it lets
us all live at a higher standard of
living in this country and we need to
have sort of unilateral disarmament in
the trade wars we need to open up our
trade policy for free trade with all
countries it will reduce the amount of
strife we have overseas reduce the
amount of conflict and really improve
the quality of life for all Americans
how do you sell that to people who are
like yeah I don't think so
what you have to talk to is what it is
that they're looking for a lot of the
Trump voters were looking for safety and
security and the idea that we'd get past
this stagnation we've had where you have
a generation of Millennials who are
looking at potentially having a lower
standard of living on their parents did
the way you solve that is by not trying
to fight against disruption in the
market not trying to fight against
people coming here to build a better
life but welcoming them in and helping
everyone succeed the market itself will
make better quality of life across the
board for everyone yes there will be job
losses in certain industries but in a
robust market where the economy is
growing we're better able to have
policies to deal with that than we are
trying to throw up a wall and say nobody
else come here final thoughts on the
Garry Johnson candidacy he tripled or
more I guess more than tripled previous
high points totals for an LP
presidential candidate and yet there was
a widespread sense that he didn't quite
hit the mark that he might have what are
your thoughts on that you know it's it's
really you can look at it both ways if
you look at it from the expectations of
what people thought he might have been
able to do he didn't hit some people's
marks if you look at it from historical
expectations from what we've previously
done he blew everything out of the water
what we're focused on now is building
off of that momentum whether it was
locker serendipity or his hard work that
led to the high vote totals the
increased voter registration the
defections the revenue numbers all of
these things I can't say what I can say
is we're going to try and build off of
it so that 2018 and then 2020 are even
more successful well we'll leave it
there thanks so much for talking thanks
for having me we've been talking with
Nicholas sorbic he's the chairman of the
libertarian party for reason I'm
collapsing
[Music]
you